it's often with bio pics you've got to
audiences in mind you've got the people
who don't know who it is you're making
the film about and you've got the rabid
fans too and it seems like a tightrope
that you'd have to walk the way I look
at it is that there is no tightrope
really to walk you just kind of have to
do what you think is the right thing to
do but I think that you don't believe
and I didn't go into it thinking I've
got to satisfy any group of people in
fact when I talked to the family and
it's a pretty complicated families you
can imagine when they I told him first
time I talked to all of them sort of
separately and they said well you know
we think this and we think there's a I
said you know the truth is I hate
talking to families when you're making a
movie about families you said that Thun
I said it to him I said because all of
you all have different ideas i said i
can't really try to satisfy you make you
happy i can just do what I think is the
best for the film as I've you know
imagined it it was based on a book so
you had that as a starting point but
there are probably so many biopics that
have died aborning because of questions
of rights and this one in particular
it's all about the music well it was a
really interesting situation and that
says because i didn't really option the
book until after i finished the script i
wrote the script a lot of people were
talking about the rights and rights are
incredibly complicated as we all know
and everybody this room certainly knows
and I took I done enough different
things that I decided with some helps
them from you know lawyer that I talked
to that you know Hanks rights were
probably he was public domain in terms
of Hank here's a he's a very famous
person he'd been written about millions
of different ways there's 37 different
books that I looked at personally not to
mention all the magazine articles and so
I was told well you'll need the family
you'll need this that and I said I don't
think so and so I wrote the script
without anybody's rights any of the
family's rights and then i had read all
these different books but Colin s cots
book was by far the best it was academic
it wasn't dry was really
the thorough really was impressed with
it my copy looked like it looks like the
Gutenberg Bible it's so old and torn up
and paste it and and I did that and then
once I was realized what the film was
going to be in what I narrowed down to
shoot and so forth and I understood who
the different people were that who were
still alive whose rights i would need I
went to them for instance the gal who
plays Billie Jean Billie Jean is the 19
year old that he married at the end of
his life he he married her in October he
died in December as you know and and
Billie Jean still alive and she's one of
the few so is lacretia the old that the
daughter who was his stepdaughter
Audrey's goes she's still alive and I
went to them because they're alive and I
didn't even though they're represented
very you know carefully and the thing
and Billie Jean is I don't know how old
billie jean is not what she she's up
there and and she has a minder and I
really want to make sure she was okay
and I didn't know in what sense Billie
Jean was that coach in about self and
when I talked to Betty the woman who
looked after everybody said well you
know she comes in and out what do you
want to do and I said well I want her to
be okay I said but I've written it is i
have understood it and she said okay so
she said well why don't you send a
script to me saw sent to scrub and
billie jean has got she's got fire red
hair now I mean just you know just she
was beautiful woman and and just read
like your hair is actually and she is so
that her Betty red or the stuff last of
it and and I said so Betty call me and
she said you're good to go I said what
Billie Jean say she said he'll that's
funky and I'm funky I'd say that was a
yes so how was that's at all right
that's good by me there were so many
ways to approach his life yes why did
you make the choices that you did in
terms of we meet him pretty much as an
adult and we see a musical career in a
personal career and bringing a bit of
Hollywood bring in a bit of New York how
did you make those choices I love that
because the
to me it was the fundamental question
about how I was going to make the movie
I kind of hate the word biopic what I
felt like is it i I've never was that
very interested in stories about
analyzing how someone becomes who they
are so I'd never wanted to tell the
story from the cradle to the grave it
was really important to me not to do
that many of the filmmakers who I admire
and people that I don't I could use
their names but I don't put myself
anywhere near their class of people but
whether you're talking about a bob fosse
or you're talking to though kinds of
films that made films about various
people or never did that as well I and I
love those pictures I so I did I knew
that he was taught how to play a guitar
by an elderly african-american guy named
T Todd I knew everything about him but I
wasn't interested in it I didn't in the
sense that that's not that unusual to me
somebody had to teach him how to play
the guitar at the same time I was
adamant that I didn't want to have any
scenes in the film where he was shown
really writing those things are really
rough when you show somebody sitting
down and have an inspiration and some
epiphany and I just find them hard to
believe so I made up my mind and i've
been criticized for by various people
well why don't you show him how great he
was and i said well you know i don't
know how to explain how great and i
don't know how to explain how a kid out
of the dirt from Mount Olive Alabama
could actually do what he did I often
say this if you can explain to me how
Bob Zimmerman from Hibbing Minnesota
whose dad ran a furniture store becomes
Bob Dylan I'll explain Hank Williams so
I just felt like what I and what I
wanted to try to do and did to the best
of my ability to accomplish was to show
the his life that these lives of that
this young young man and his
relationships is his difficult
tempestuous relationships with his first
wife wouldn't with women in general the
burden that that cause and so often most
much art is created out of that between
men and women whether it's a woman as an
artist or a man as an artist somewhere
their relationships have profound
influence and I want I thought well i'm
going to show his life actually the
things sometimes mundane sometimes but
now
well sometimes things that we all
understand these are the things that
took place and from that you will
understand where his music came from did
it make a difference in getting the
picture made that you had Tom Hiddleston
who was so committed I guess to the role
well in the beginning the the funny
thing about Tom and it's such a honor to
be here at the academy because I've been
a member for I don't you know a while
and you know it's a big deal but I was
thinking when I was walking in here that
but then I remember the first time I saw
Tom Hiddleston was in the Academy
because it was a premiere for war horse
and when I asked Tom to do the movie
nobody knew who tom was Thor hadn't come
out Avengers hadn't come out he was a
very unknown actor but I was completely
taken with him and it was a complete gut
decision that he was the guy and in fact
it wasn't of any value to me at all when
I probably the as I tell the story
friends money said it started out like
this first tell him I've hired Tom
Hiddleston or I've asked Tom Hiddleston
to be in the movie and people said who's
Tom Hiddleston wait what are you talking
about and then about eight months later
they went well why'd you hire Tom
Hiddleston and then about six months
after that everybody said hey man how'd
you get Tom here so you know I thought I
think it helped I hope it helps people
go see the movie but I think that in
fact it by the time the movie was being
made it was a value and Elizabeth as
well who I just adore in the movie she
plays Audrey elizabeth Olsen she's just
I just think she gives such a fantastic
performance and she's such a great great
talent he's been dead for so long but
people have almost separated him from
his music yeah people know the covers to
the music rather than the original and
yet he came in at a time and was a
crossover figure when the late 40s early
50s as far as I could tell was sort of a
desert of pop music I mean when how much
is that doggie in the window hit number
one this is before Elvis before the
Beatles so the significance of his
character can't be of his musical
contributions can't be underestimated
and came through to me
that's one point you wanted to make it
was because I approached Hank even
though I grew up in the South I grew up
in Kentucky in Louisville Kentucky which
is not really a south but if you ask
everybody's a little Kentucky they think
their southern but it's the Midwest
really but is three hours north of
Nashville and I was a huge country-music
fan so I've always known the music
however the thing that I was always
moved by was what a brilliant writer he
was and many of my friends who were
writers in that I know had talked about
him is one of the greatest poets of the
20th century American poets and I do
believe that and and so I mean at the
time if you think about what he did
first of all he been Crosby was gigantic
then and and you know and everybody
wanted to sing like being crud Bob Dylan
still talks about singing and said well
everybody wants this thing like you know
Bing Crosby in terms of Hank to me what
his what was most significant was his
writing I mean here's a man when you
think of the pop stuff that was being
written at the time and yes how much is
a dog you been also you know springtown
beautiful songs by some really Tony
Bennett and so forth but no guy no man
was singing I'm so lonesome I could cry
no no way and and then also pouring out
the heart these profound Lee's that song
of you know and anger unkind words are
said that make the teardrop start how
can i free you're doubtful mind and melt
your cold gold heart and that's why I
started the movie the way I did because
I knew a lot of people wouldn't know his
music in that way and I wanted and hoped
and I hope it will resonate it for the
people who were here today for you all
to be able to watch and just be forced
to listen to his poetry and that's why I
started it sort of out of place and out
of time the the use of narrators you've
got the Bradley Whitford character from
our Fred Rose is it Fred Fred rose red
rose and you bring those voices in too
to what purpose why did you think you
needed those well fred was a profound
influence on Hank by the way Red Rose
was of songwriters you know the song
that will least
you've heard Delinda Raza you know blue
eyes crying in the rain red rose wrote
that song and that's why I Hank had such
respect for him the reason I did that
was I feel like I just have such a I
can't stand when I have to listen to in
a story to a lot of exposition and when
I try to write my dialogue so that
there's no exposition in it because very
rarely do people have exposition when
you're talking remember when we met at
so-and-so so I felt like how do I get
around having Hank in all this
information be somebody so that these
relationships in these conversations
that take place can take place between
people and have them be real that's why
in some of the conversations they don't
even answer each other he asked a
question and she has come another
questions again and so I I mean you know
I sort of I kind of crypt it to be
honest you know Lenny uses it in Bob
posses movie Lenny the Dustin Hoffman
film and he used some footage like that
when she's his wife's interview Valerie
prayin and I kind of thought I love that
idea and so I sort of stole that from
mr. Fosse please thank Mark Abraham
thank you